sie transportiert material von bis zu 3
5 tonnen auf berge über schluchten und
flüsse
seit 2008 ist die die bircks bewegliche
pionierkompanie des pionierbataillons
zeigt in weiß in salzburg für die
seilbahn einsätze zuständig wir
befördern von kleinen pionier maschinen
über lang gut holz was zum bau verwendet
wird betonkübel mit schotter sand oder
beton und notfalls auch eine
personenbergung grundwehrdiener der
salzburger pioniere führten anfang juli
auf dem schießplatz felixdorf
ausnahmsweise in ebenem gelände zwei
wochen lang trainings einsätze mit einer
versuch seilbahn anlage durch konkrete
ideen der steiger einkleben jetzt auf
die stütze hinaufgeklettert wir frei
sagt man sehen weil 25m pappenstiel
laden lehrerin geht kraft haben
anstrengend ist es auch eingesetzt wurde
die pionier seilbahn schon mehrmals zur
holz bringen denn jedes forsten in
hochfilzen und in der wattener lizum in
tirol personentransporte mit der pionier
silvan sind nur im notfall erlaubt im
falle einer notrettung um erste hilfe
maßnahmen sicherstellen zu können ist
der selben zug der salzburger pioniere
in der lage auch diese notrettung und in
weiterer folge erste hilfe maßnahmen
durchführen zu können
der retter hängt sich an die berge trage
überwacht den verunfallten während des
transports und verhindert verdrehungen
und erschütterungen beim passieren der
stützen für die steuerung der seilbahn
ist der zugkommandant zuständig per funk
gibt es eine kommandos an den seilwinden
für mit hilfe eines lastwagens auf einem
laufwagen können zum beispiel pioneer
maschinen auf dem 24 millimeter starken
drahtseil in die höhe gezogen werden 1
11 millimeter dick das zugseil zieht
über 80 ps starke winde die maschine wie
hier einen ketten dampfer bergwärts soll
die last talwärts befördert werden lässt
der winken bürgersaal nach den auf wagen
fährt so dann aufgrund der geneigten
bahn führung durch die schwerkraft von
selbst bergergut manuel hüttl untergrund
lukas tornauer von pini bataillon zwei
sind anfang april zum grundwehrdienst
eingerückt und haben wir jetzt das seit
anfang dieses jahres verpflichtende
katastrophenschutz module absolviert war
lernt dabei alles kennen das man sie
damals sicher ist man lernt die
persönliche schutzausrüstung kann was
man für verschiedene werkzeuge braucht
jeweils verschiedene schutzausrüstung
das muss man als ich noch ein kleiner
das ist eigentlich der hauptgrund warum
er das ganze macht einmal kennenlernen
führen einsatz dass man das alles dann
kann